rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message follow
your dreams
over you APJ Abdul Kalam how did you
become so great
how did I become so great that's a
question well which class you're singing
what's your dream in life well you know
give the related terms so I personally
believe you Basava dream say you must I
must have a dream I must continuously
acquire knowledge continuously acquire
knowledge hard work hard work and
perseverance
one should not be of awana
not afraid of problems ok so the advice
here sounds really simple because he's
talking to a child but it's also true
and it's very powerful if you look at
anybody who's had massive success look
at the people who you look up to your
idols your heroes people you want to
have the same level of impact as they
had a dream they took action they follow
through they were consistent they worked
hard and every day they just took more
steps towards achieving their dream even
when it didn't make sense even when they
had a lot of doubters and haters even
one in their own mind they're like this
will never become anything like how am I
ever gonna turn this into something they
just kept going they kept following
through they kept doing it there's a
great quote from Bill Gates that I was
reading this morning in my book atop the
roses success where they were debating
the future of the industry computers and
everybody knew she was on one side and
Bill Gates was on the other side and
what the people on the other side said
was Bill Gates is probably wrong but he
worked so hard he worked so much harder
than us that he'll find a way to make it
right and that idea that you can work so
hard you could change an entire industry
that just by continuing to grind the
hustle to do your thing every single day
eventually will work out and this is
almost every single success story if you
want to look at my example I started
helping entrepreneurs when I did
speeches at the YMCA and my first event
three people showed up to a free event
and if I was just looking for the next
business opportunity that would be a
pass like three people show up to a free
thing how does this become a business it
doesn't it doesn't make sense it's not
practical it's not logical quit go do
something else
but I loved it I loved helping those
three entrepreneurs you know I was a
little disappointed walking in the room
at the beginning but I did my speech and
I helped them like I have to do this
again I have to find a way to keep going
I don't care if I ever get paid I just
need to keep doing this because it fills
my soul and then every day I just kept
taking consistent action the thing that
holds people back is just they don't
follow through enough you're trying to
make sense of it you're trying to make
it practical you kind of make it
rational you have real-life pressures of
bills and all this stuff coming at you
you need to find time for your passion
you've got to find ways to put one foot
in front of the other and just keep
going and with time with enough time
with continued effort I promise you it's
gonna work out it won't be as fast as
you want and it won't look like you
think it's for the look like you'll take
a lot of detours and turns along the
road to get to the place where you want
to be but I promise you that just
everyday you have a dream you have a
vision you have something that you love
doing do that every day add value to
other people's lives it's gonna pay off
just stay consistent and believe so the
question they today is I'm curious I
want to set a mini milestone for you
when you feel like not working on your
business when you feel like things are
too rough too much life is in the way
too many demands in your time you're
sick you've got family matters to deal
with when when all those pressures are
piling up on you what's the one thing
that you can still do in your business
what's one action then you can promise
yourself that you will still take even
if it takes you just five minutes to do
some small action and you can put into
your business that even when the world
is against you and you feel like we're
giving up they're gonna take some small
daily consistent action
what is that action leaving the comments
below I want to see what you have to say
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Kareem Kareem Kareem thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you and I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events best
[Music]
it's important to me to have the balls
to look at the biggest problems we face
as a society and say that's my problem
to solve right obesity metabolic disease
the slide towards ill health however you
want to categorize it that's my problem
like I don't even wake up thinking
that's my business partners problem
that's my problem you know I'm working
with my business partners because a very
sharp guys yeah
but at the end of the day like I own
that responsibility and that's awesome
to me right like having that it isn't a
weight that drags me down it's like this
goal to chase that's so big that I'm
just stoked that there are people in the
world debt are prepared to dream that
big like I'm inspired by that in others
and hopefully can inspire other people
with our dream is it an abundance of
creativity or energy or strategy or all
of it or lack of sleep lack of sleep I
think it's just I like I said this is
just when I I wouldn't want to do
anything else in life besides make stuff
all I want to do is make stuff and if
that's your goal then you can do that
whether they're paying for your movies
or not you can go grab an iPhone and
leave and go out front here and like go
make a short with your friends and
that's what I would be doing if I wasn't
lucky enough to get to make movies and
stuff like that this business is so
weird that like if this isn't the only
thing you want to do in life then leave
the room and don't do it you know what I
mean but if it's the only thing you want
to do in life and you can't imagine
doing anything else
then don't worry about how much time
it's taking it will happen in whatever
incarnation it's supposed to happen in
but you have to just make stuff
constantly
and don't worry about like making it
make stuff that sounded smart
in eighth grade the vice-principal told
my mother I wasn't going to amount to
anything there's not a school for what
it is that I have had you know I didn't
go to film school I'm a filmmaker how
did I get there when I was a young kid I
didn't know that there was such a thing
as a director
forget about white or black but that
there was such a thing that a director
was my dad was a cop that was killed in
the line of duty
my mom was left who raised me and my
siblings on her own I knew that I was
drawn to Hollywood I still didn't really
know that I wanted to direct this girl
that I was dating the only girl that
I've ever dated gave me seven dollars so
I had seven dollars and a bus ticket and
a dream
when I came to Los Angeles I was
actually homeless and I didn't think
much about it I was okay it snuck into
the back of a church and I stayed there
and the pastor discovered me and said if
you want to stay here you got it clean I
said okay I'll see you know and I notice
that there was a theater that was there
I knew I could write I know it was a
storyteller and I said you mind if I put
on one acts here that's my first time
actually directing and I knew that that
was meant for me that whatever was my
destiny was on the stage that will
change my life
I learned from the streets I've used my
life experiences and everything you see
up on that screen is my life and I'm not
afraid to tell you my life
is eNOS with an artist does wasn't until
I felt comfortable with my sexuality and
my color that my dreams were becoming
fulfilled raise your standard Apple at
the cool its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's something to me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details